protestas tuvieron lugar en varias
ciudades de Estados Unidos en reaccionar
el vídeo de la muerte de tyricles El
afroamericano de 29 años falleció tras
recibir múltiples golpes por parte de
cinco policías también afrodescendientes
luego de haber sido detenido por una
infracción de tráfico
hemos visto durante años y décadas que
los policías afroamericanos han hecho
por su trabajo lo mismo y han servido al
mismo sistema de supremacía blanca y del
capital Así que es enfermizo es
repugnante pero están haciendo su
trabajo están haciendo lo que vinieron a
hacer que es aterrorizar a las
comunidades para mantener el control
la indignación por este nuevo hecho de
violencia policial es aún mayor ya que
casos como este siguen sucediendo dos
años después del asesinato de George
Floyd el hombre afroamericano que murió
producto de la asfixia que fue sometido
por el oficial en Minneapolis en mayo de
2020 su muerte generó una ola de en todo
el país
este año o justo el año pasado vimos las
tasas más altas de asesinatos policiales
en este país no vamos a tolerarlo en
2020 tomamos las calles y nos quedamos
en las calles millones de personas en
este país lideraron un levantamiento y
vamos a hacer lo que haga falta No solo
para que se haga justicia sino para
asegurarnos de que esta brutalidad llega
a su fin de una vez por todas según un
recuento del Washington post 2022 fue el
año más mortífero en Estados Unidos
respecto a la violencia policial en los
últimos 12 meses 1110 personas han
muerto por disparos de fuerzas de
seguridad
proporcionalmente los afroamericanos
mueren a manos de la policía dos veces
más que los estadounidenses blancos